[Music]
thank you
one of these days
I'm gonna Wake Up Older with a hole in
your pocket
and a blade on your shoulder
if you break both in legs so don't come
running to me I had a change of heart
better change of heart
worry about the war
nobody's winning
worry about the rain
it's only beginning
I never loved you when I always will had
a change of heart
and a change of heart
get down to the end of the line
and it all fell apart
quit trying to change your mind
I had a change of heart
[Music]
I had a change of heart
[Music]
where I am
[Music]
tolerable
you run from danger
straight into trouble
way down deep you just a shallow with me
I had a change
of heart
unwanted child
with an absent mother
want protection
like an older brother
I remember
forgetting all the words that you said I
had a change of heart I had a change of
heart
get down to the end of the line
and it all fell apart
quit trying to change the past
[Music]
I had a change of heart
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]